welcome back to cbs this morning we have
new information about allegations
that women at an immigration detention
center in georgia
are getting unwanted medical procedures
maria villarreal spoke exclusively to
one former detainee who says
after her unexpected surgery she may now
be unable to have children
maria these are very troubling
allegations what did she tell you
gail they are she was very emotional
when she spoke with us yesterday pauline
bynum was picked up by ice in 2017 and
was fighting her deportation
she says while she was in custody she
was subjected to an invasive medical
procedure without proper preparation
or education the pain
was pretty intense colleen bynum says
she was diagnosed with ovarian cysts
while fighting her immigration case from
the irwin county detention center in
georgia
she was told she needed an operation
where he was supposed to take the cysts
off my ovaries either by scraping them
or draining them
that's what i consented to do and what
happened he said yes he removed the cyst
but there was some blockage in my right
fallopian tube and he took it out
he did it while i was already down on
the table on anesthesia so
i couldn't have consented to it medical
documents confirmed that bynum had a
portion of her right fallopian tube
removed and she was bothered
that she went into surgery expecting a
different procedure
he said that the only way i would have
kids again is through ivf
how does that sit with you pauline i
started crying i still don't know how to
accept that because
not that i wanted a big family but
cbs news has obtained records from two
other women who claim doctors at the
same facility
perform procedures they didn't fully
understand it made me
queasy don wooten a former nurse at
irwin filed a whistleblower complaint
alleging widespread lack of proper
informed consent for medical procedures
there was a woman who actually came to
you and said this happened to me
i don't know why nobody told me this was
going to happen to me
that was what i was told and you know
you just jaw drop
senator i agree with you that those
would be uh those are shocking
allegations
this week senior officials from the
department of homeland security told
senators the inspector general is
investigating these claims
some of the facts on the ground and the
facts that we have seen do not back up
those allegations
i'm still shocked houston congresswoman
sheila jackson lee helped prevent
bynum's deportation and
is pushing for a bigger investigation it
may be closing this facility
if it cannot be repaired these women are
in civil
detention they have rights
they have rights as women and they have
human rights
to this day bynum continues to sort out
what happened to her
i'm still in the process of going to get
a physical exam so i can find out what
really happened
while there are still several questions
about what allegedly happened at or when
the procedures there there is a
congressional delegation that is set to
visit the facility later today we
understand that they are looking and
hoping for more complete medical records
that will help them answer some of those
questions that have been posed by bynum
and several other women who lawyers say
have raised similar allegations of
medical
mistreatment or procedures being done at
the facility
without proper consent we will stay on
top of this
anthony such a disturbing story maria
thank you